here's a great example
of the libs
disingenuously
silencing victims
weeks after Alex Jones was ordered by a
judge
to pay about one billion dollars to the
family of the Sandy Hook shooting
victims
Bloomberg News is reporting that the
Sandy Hook families have have now
demanded
2.75 trillion dollars
an additional 2.75 trillion dollars
not all that far off from the GDP of the
United States I mean it's a little ways
to go but you know in reason if you go
back just a few decades you're pretty
much there
and they've done this by uh taking the
maximum penalty allowed under state law
five thousand dollars multiplying it by
the 550 million social media views that
Alex Jones got on his social media
accounts in the three years following
the the Sandy Hook school shooting and
now they are demanding
upwards of three
trillion dollars
from a radio host
for saying for getting a story wrong on
air
and and even and saying let's say
they're saying mean things Terrible
Things the worst things you could
possibly say three trillion dollars for
saying that on the radio
does that seem a little disproportionate
when I think
of the sort of things that the Democrats
have said in public
when the Democrats have called for
physical when when mainstream Democrats
have called for physical violence
against Republicans in public when
Maxine Waters says when you see
Republicans in public push back on them
say you're not welcome here
chasing them out of restaurants when
Maxine waters's go to Republicans homes
shout outside where their children sleep
shout outside their homes
when when Chuck Schumer says we're
coming for you Brett Kavanaugh we're
coming for you Gorsuch we're going to
unleash the Whirlwind on you and then
what hat lo and behold what happens some
left left-wing lunatic goes in and tries
to murder Justice Kavanaugh
and gets pretty close actually before
the U.S Marshals were able to stop him
when some left-wing lunatic goes in and
shoots up the Congressional baseball
game to kill the Republicans almost
kills Steve scalise
and you hear nothing
you're nothing from the Democrats when
when Hillary Clinton says you can't be
civil with Republicans
none of that they're not going to pay
three trillion dollars to say nothing of
what the cop the pundits or whatever say
in the air they're not gonna pay three
trillion dollars
and who knows where the three the 2.75
trillion dollar lawsuit is going to go
Alex Jones was already ordered to pay a
billion dollars
you think any for what for getting a
story wrong on it that's basically what
you could say well he got it egregiously
wrong he it was the worst way you could
possibly get a story wrong sure whatever
but the actual category of of
transgression that Alex Jones committed
is he got a story wrong on air you're
telling me that the punishment for that
should be one billion dollars
or I'm sorry 2.75
trillion dollars doesn't that seem a
little disproportionate to you
especially when the libs would never pay
one red Cent for doing far more
egregious things no it's obviously not
about the transgression it's simply
about punishing dissidents the libs hate
Alex Jones they want to silence him they
will use whatever excuse they can to do
it and they will come down on him with
as much crushing weight as they can
possibly wield up to and including three
trillion bucks
speaking of the courts there's there's
some good news that's come out of the
course incredible news actually that
came out of the course yesterday in New
York
a New York judge
has ruled that the city must reinstate
the fired city workers with back pay who
lost their jobs because they refused to
take the fauci ouchy and here's why
here's the the best part is the reason
why the court has come to this finding
the court found that quote being
vaccinated does not prevent an
individual from Contracting or
transmitting covid-19
they added that vaccinated and
unvaccinated individuals have the same
quarantine and isolation guidelines
issued by the CDC
that's why
and there were at the time we were all
told by the by the libs and the squishes
we were told you have to get the vaccine
come on maybe we don't support the
mandates but you should all get it
now we find actually the vaccines don't
do what they said
what we were told that they would do and
they do a lot of things that we were
told they wouldn't do
furthermore the judge goes on the
vaccine mandate for city employees was
not just about public safety and public
health it was about compliance
if it was about safety and public health
unvaccinated workers would have been
placed on leave the moment the order was
issued great point
it was not but instead that workers were
pressured pressured still come to your
job but pressured get it get it get it
if it were about a health emergency
there's no way that would have happened
if you were about a health emergency
they would have said go home get wear a
hazmat suit get out of here
how many workers lost their jobs because
of this
people have written into this show a lot
and lost their jobs because of it I'm
I'm very fortunate I work at a company
that not only did not have a vaccine
mandate but that sued the Biden
Administration to stop the vaccine
mandate
is what were we going to do we had
meeting what were we going to do if we
lost that lawsuit well one we were all
going to get audited to the hilt we were
all going to become we might still but
we were all going to become major
targets of the federal government but
two even if that's still probably going
to happen two
what were we going to do they the
federal government could have come in
and bankrupted the company
pretty quickly actually
so we fought it we didn't have to do it
same cannot be said for a ton of other
companies and certainly city workers
Eric Adams fired 2 000 just about 2 000
city workers including cops including
firefighters who refused to comply with
the coveted vaccination mandate
now the court is ordering him to
reinstate them with back pay which is
absolutely right and just will he do it
remains to be seen will the city appeal
almost certainly
this is probably a little soft
consolation of the workers who lost
their jobs they've been out of work for
a year
and so it's a reminder as well looking
forward into the future
the next time we're told by the entire
establishment this is fact this is
science you have to do it this is
coercion do it now do it now you'll lose
everything do it now do it now if you if
you can hold firm if you can have a
little bit of Courage keep the you
you may see Justice all hope is not lost
you may see Justice we are still in this
fight the Democrats are Running Scared
though they're they're not omnipotent
they can feel their grasp on power
weakening just now is it going to is are
they going to lose that grasp entirely
tomorrow or two weeks from now probably
not
but they can feel it weakening and and
the truth is on our side and the people
are seeing that they're seeing it more
and more each day as we approach those
midterm elections now
unbelievably unbelievably
it seems that I have some critics
I reacted to some woke tick-tockers
nonsense about religion he appears to
have reacted to my reaction and so in a
full sort of Inception
I will be critiquing his critique of my
critique of his nonsense because this of
course is woke Wednesday the rest of the
show continues now you don't want to
miss it if you're not a member click the
link in the description and join us
[Music]
foreign